watching Al Jazeera a reminder of our
headlines this hour former president and
leftist leader Lula de Silva has been
declared the winner of a knife edge
presidential runoff election with over
99 percent of ballots counted he has
taken 50.9 percent of the vote incumbent
jair bolsonaro took 49.1 percent
of Lula de Silva or in the streets
celebrating an extraordinary comeback
for the man who previously served two
terms as president he also served time
in prison for corruption but was
released after the Supreme federal court
of Brazil ruled the judge wasn't
impartial
meanwhile supporters of incumbent
bolsonaro have been left in near
disbelief the right-wing leader has not
yet made a speech conceding the election
Brazilian State media is however
reporting that the presidents of
Congress and the president of the Senate
have both acknowledged Lula's Victory
and crucially they are both political
allies of bolsonaro
so Lula will lead Latin America's
biggest economy over the next four years
our Latin America editor Lucia Newman
visited his home Village in the lead-up
to this poll
she reports from pranam bucco one of the
country's poorest regions
a remote Dirt Road in northeastern
Brazil the country's poorest region this
is where edaldo Santos takes us to see
where his cousin Luis Da Silva was born
or at least an exact replica of the home
of donalindu Luna's mother
the original fell down years ago
this was the typical House of
subsistence Farmers made of mud and
coconut tree sticks with no running
water or electricity
it's important to reconstruct this story
for future Generations so they can
assimilate Lula's story and realize that
they too can fight for Collective
Justice in these times of individualism
this was the bedroom with a family of
ten slept and this suitcase was used as
a closet until Lula's mother who was
illiterate decided to take all of her
children to Sao Paulo never dreaming who
one of her youngest sons would
eventually become
working at the age of 14 and went on to
become a formidable Trade union leader
and founder of the workers party or PT
he had little formal education but an
abundance of Charisma and negotiating
skills
in 2003 Lula became Brazil's first
working-class president
he introduced sweeping social reforms to
combat poverty and lift the station of
working-class Brazilians from providing
education
to fresh water access for people like
Paolo Gomez
I began to love Lula long ago like a
father a hero because honestly he
Embraces the cause of the poor
massive housing projects also helped
lift 33 million people from poverty
during his two terms which coincided
with the Boom in prices for Brazilian
commodities
Brazil's economy sword
it all was not well nagging charges of
corruption had long surrounded him and
his political party
a multi-billion dollar graph Scandal
exploded after he left office in 2010
just as the economy began regressing
millions of Brazilians turned on Lula
demanding he go to jail
if Lula is not in prison he will return
to power and keep stealing he's the
ringleader of them all
he was convicted and imprisoned on
charges of money laundering and
Corruption which he denied but was
released 18 months later when the
Supreme Court ruled that all of Lula's
convictions be annulled because of
suspect procedural practices
now 12 years after he left office with
more than 80 percent approval ratings in
older and perhaps more cautious Lula has
returned promising to bring back better
days especially for the poor
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera caite Brazil
let's bring in Nelson Franco Jobim he's
a professor at Helio Alonso University
specializing in international politics
and he joins us from Rio de Janeiro so
there's been no official reaction from
the man who is still president as we
speak jair bolsonaro should that concern
Brazilians
well
um well yes as I heard in your report
the presidents of the the two houses of
Congress
have
recognized the the victory of Lula and
especially the leader of the house
is a is a strong bolsonaro supporter he
didn't put through more than 130
impeachment
requests against bolsonaro so he's he's
a great Alliance of President bolsonaro
and Sobo sanar won't have any support
for uh an attempt not to recognize the
result of the elections but he can he
may create problems with the transition
periods I think that monike
talked about that
um
well we're still waiting to see what
they are going to say but neither
bolsonaro nor his sons who the three old
uh all the sense are politicians uh have
not said anything about the results
yeah sorry about these statements coming
from the the presidents of uh Congress
and presidents of the Senate
acknowledging Lula's Victory do you
expect that they are acting in concert
with bolsonaro do you expect that
they're actually trying to maybe narrow
his options
I think they're trying to narrow himself
his options and uh arturia the president
of the house called Lula and
congratulated Lula for the victory of
course there will be elections for the
the leader of the House the at the
beginning of the next year and uh
probably our two little ones to to keep
the job so he's trying to negotiate with
fluent and he he is a member of the
so-called Central it's which means big
Center which in reality is the center
right politicians who don't have strong
ideological positions but try to jockey
for positions try to get some
um federal funds and jobs for for allies
so this is the kind of of that which is
who are going to negotiate with Rule and
probably
assured I would say will support Lula's
administration of course there is a a
larger
group of backbenchers elected on the
bolsonaro
based on the bolsonaro ideas who will be
against Lula particularly the the
Evangelical Christians and and the big
and the representative of the big
farmers
but uh a leader and and the president of
the Senate
gave the clear
impression that bolsonar won't have many
allies to try to not accept the results
so Brazilian institutions proved to be
strong enough to resist for four years
of bolsonaro right-wing far-right-wing
governments and I'm sure they will
manage this transition yeah of course
both sonadism is going to to to be a
strong political force the main
opposition Force but Brazil will go on
and of uh and another the other problem
is the economic situation is very bad
when ruler was elected in 2002 he
benefited from the reforms of of the
Fernandez Cardozo Administration and
China was growing more than 10 percent a
year and became the largest trading
partner of Brazil so the Nelson I'm
gonna have to jump in
okay all right thank you thank you so
much you've been with us since the
beginning of the evening uh and
certainly there are many other uh areas
of this conversation that we'll have to
explore but we'll have time for that
going forward Nelson Franco Jo beam
thank you so much
thank you